uh good afternoon everyone um welcome to
uh the first uh piece of programming
from the uh Yale program for the study
of anti-Semitism uh in the spring 20124
semester uh I'm David Walsh um I am the
post-doctoral associate um at the
program for the study of
anti-Semitism um and I want to welcome
uh this afternoon uh
uh who will be giving a talk
anti-Semitism and racism a shared
history uh just introduce Professor
tedar briefly she is the professor of
history and schidler chair of judaic
studies at forom University uh she's the
author of Jews and Heretics in Catholic
Poland Sinners on trial Jews in
sacrilege after the Reformation Blood
liel on the trail of an anti-semitic
myth uh which won the National Jewish
book award in 2020 it's fantastic book I
highly recommend it to you all and most
recently Christian Supremacy Reckoning
with the roots of anti-Semitism and
racism which was published in
2023 um Professor tedor has received
fellowships from the John Simon
gugenheim Memorial Foundation the Harry
Frank gugenheim Foundation uh the
Harvard Radcliffe Institute the Coleman
Center at the New York Public Library
the National Endowment for the the
National Endowment for the Humanities
excuse me and uh others uh professor
tedar is currently the president of the
American Academy of Jewish research so
we are very very pleased and very
honored that she is with us today and
Professor tedar please make it
work thank you so much for having me um
I'm delighted to be with you to today
and to share um my work and my screen
with you um
so uh let me do that um so let me first
um say if a few words about how this
book came about because I was uh trained
as a historian of Jewish history a
Jewish experience uh my early work is in
Eastern Europe uh Poland polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth and then um I
expanded a little bit
geographically uh but this book really
uh is one that reaches across
fields and um one of the reasons why I
was I've been thinking um that we need
to rethink and find new approaches to um
the study of anti-Semitism is that I've
been frustrated with the historiography
of anti-Semitism uh Scholars have been
debating over
um um definitions over spelling uh what
time periods what's the difference
between anti-judaism anti-jewish
anti-judaic anti-Semitism judeophobia
um is um now we're obviously discussing
and the question of anti-zionism and
anti-Semitism is this eternal hatred is
it a modern phenomenon and these debates
uh you know producing lots of books um
and articles and and scholarly
conversations have never sort of failed
for me that they are really um really
getting us somewhere and I'm not the
first one David angle just told us to
get rid of all the definitions and move
and discuss what was really happening
and then I had this sort of Revelation
um in 20 2016 when I was at the premiere
of um rul peek's film I am not your
negro in which he uh play has this this
clip of James Baldwin and the PBS
program the new Grand American promise
in which um in which um Baldwin um uh
uses the nword very emphatically and
very consciously I will not use it but
uh saying essentially asking why is it
why was why it was necessary to have the
n in the first place because I am not an
an I am a man um and if you think that I
am an it means that you need him and if
you and I'm not the N here then you and
you invented him you the white people
invented him then you have to find out
why and that when I saw the scene it was
this big Revelation said this is exactly
like the Jew invented by uh by
Christians and just to give you a sense
of both what bwin meant and what I mean
by the sort of caricature of a a person
of a of an image that doesn't really
exist and has nothing to do with the
living uh either in James Baldwin's
Place uh black people or Jews in in the
case of of the Jews so the example of
the the and the creation of that uh of
that caricature in contrast to whiteness
um is uh are are some of the
illustrations in a in a very um uh in a
book that actually argued for against
the very Humanity of black people here
um and and here's another example ja
supposing the you know white bodies
against the caricatured black uh body
and here is an example of um of a this
is a Nazi children's book of the
contrast between the um the Aryan German
and the the Jew um here is a Fagan
from uh from Oliver Twist um uh and
again you can sort of see the the girl
and the aesthetic of the girl girl
versus the the representation of the Jew
and very very similar uh terms of
presentation and contrast
so I've been reading um and learning
about um black history and American
history just for my own um
interest um because again I was I grew
up in Europe and then I was trained in
the United States in Jewish history uh
but on my own I was reading um on black
history and one of the things that kept
I kept marking on the margins of the
books that I was reading is s
similarities between um the way black
people were discussed or described or um
asso ideas that were associated with and
with that what what was with Jews so we
have uh both of them were obviously
cursed by God for different reasons uh
both serve as these contract contrast
figures constitutive either in in the
case of black people of white white
Identity or in contrast of Jews really
important and con utive to Christianity
and Christian uh Christian identity both
would seen as lazy um for different
reason uh but both at the expense of uh
of in Jew's case the Christians and in
the case of black people the the white
uh
population um they were both seen as um
in different ways as arrogant insolent
uh or aathy um in in moments when they
were trying to assert their rights or
their dignity um they were both in
modern times um seen as ineligible for
citizenship because of and this is from
the people generous uh and and willing
eventually to maybe uh Grant Jews and
black people
citizenship for um after centuries of
Oppression and this sort of uh uplift
seasian idea um both both were discussed
as a question as a problem um and uh in
the modern times they were both um
refused to be accepted as equal citizens
and when they the law changed and and
both eventually reluctantly were
accepted as Citizens um there were there
was an immediate
backlash so and they were both also in
terms of the uh the seen as carnal and
then dous and here I'm going to show you
a couple of other images I here here are
some images of the leous dangerous black
men dangerous to white women um and
there is a a an an example of those
images of delous Jew and again in in
case of uh black uh Americans we know
that this often ended in lynchings um uh
the one case we know of similar uh
dynamic in America of Leo Frank was also
related to that but in in the in Europe
um that Dynamic was uh was seen in
different ways and and expressing
violence also in in different ways um so
the so so in that in my in both sort of
seeing these parallels and in my
frustration with the field of
anti-Semitism studies I've been sort of
searching for understanding and I
thought that the
the parallels are so uncanny that they
needed some explanation and the longest
hatred idea that uh that has been uh so
dominant in the scholarship on U
anti-Semitism or the modernity of anist
did not quite um feel
satisfying um so as I've been teaching
and the and again the value of
comparison was actually um again not
something that I invented um WB du Bo
after visiting Europe several times and
then the wars so get
1948 um he wrote his um essay um on the
the the Negro and the wars so ghetto in
which he highlighted the the the value
of his experiences that it helped not so
much gave him not so much Clear
understanding of the Jewish Problem in
the world as it was a real and more
complete understanding of the negro
problem so for me engaging with black
studies has given me I think a clearer
understanding of um of the Jewish
experience and Je and uh and
anti-Semitism or anti-jewish
animus um by engaging and thinking um
along the way and reading about
anti-black
racism in the 30s and and 40s other
Scholars both Jewish and and black
intellectuals uh were making connections
between um the the two uh in essays and
and uh in case of some of black um black
intellectuals to uh draw attention to
what was happening to to black people in
America uh through the experience and
concern that was raised about the Nazi
treatment of Jews before the Holocaust
in the 1930s especially and then
afterwards uh in 1948 a a really
wonderful film um strange Victory by Leo
Horwitz which I call a a poetic
meditation on racism and anti-Semitism
and I know that it seems strange but
it's a really poetic film uh that brings
these two together H and and sort of uh
combines the both the experience in
Europe and the current uh what was
current in 1948 experiences of black
Americans and also the Persistence of
anti-Semitism in America as
well so one of the the ways that
thinking and reading about
racism uh is that um that it often
focuses on structures on law on
oppression at coming not just from ideas
and um and culture although culture is
is is seen broadly but also from within
the the the role that law and and again
structural racism plays and that is
always seen in the context of power and
oppression and uh and here that help
helped me think through uh some of the
languages and hierarchies that emerg in
the uh Christian theology first about
Jews but then later on have an impact on
Law and legal framework and legal
position of Jews uh in both premodern
and modern period so let me uh flash out
the um the Theology and I'm not going to
be looking actually with the traditional
texts that uh focus on the crucifixion
or Judas or other um other parts of the
Christian scriptures but actually uh on
Paul uh and his letters because to me
they play a crucial role in um in uh the
later on framing of social hierarchies
and habits of thinking about Jews and
also legal Frameworks so uh Paul
establishes a hierarchy of
values um by Jack's deposing law that is
that for him is is Judaism and faith
that for him is this emergent
Christianity and uh uses the framework
of the two the uh two sons that that
Abraham had um Ishmael and Isaac one as
he says by a slave woman the other by a
free woman to cast them as types for
Judaism and Christianity so one the
child of a slave born according to flesh
and the other child of the free woman
born through promise um so Ishmael
through flesh from a slave woman from
Hagar and Isaac from a child of Promise
uh H and and he says there are two
symbols of the two covenants um Mount Si
Judaism bearing children for slavery and
hagga now is that is the Hagar and then
the present Jerusalem um is uh the
present Jerusalem in slavery and uh and
Jerusalem above is the free woman and um
and that is Christianity so freedom is
associated with Christianity slavery uh
and servitude with uh with Judaism and
Jerusalem uh and again he returns to it
this means that not the children of the
flesh who are the children of God but
the children of promise that is not Jews
who are observing the um the
Commandments of God as they were given
about the newly forming uh Christianity
through faith and Pro
and then he uses in an in a totally
nonsocial uh meaning but in a
theological meaning a phrase the Elder
Shall Serve the younger which comes from
the book of Genesis uh which will
really uh contribute to the creation of
legal hierarchies in uh
Christian um Europe um there were I'm
jumping centuries in the book I do a
little bit more detail but Augustine
returns to the motive of of the contrast
between carnal carnality and spirit
flesh and spirit and promise and uh and
and flesh and so on and elaborates more
on the different pairs of the of the
brothers in uh in the Bible and goes on
to detail to explain the verse what now
at the time where he lives which is when
the uh Roman Empire except is now a
formerly Christian Empire uh what in his
new historical context the Elder Shall
Serve the younger means so he says uh in
the city of God uh as to the statement
the Elder Shall Serve the younger um
scarly among anyone Omas think
understands it in any other way than the
Elder people of the Jews should serve
the younger Christian people and then
again he returned what could be clearer
than that the reference of the two
promises is that the people of
Israelites and to the the whole world
the former according to flesh and the
letter according to Faith again here
returns to those Concepts uh but that
idea of Jews serving the younger people
the Christians uh and the idea that the
Primacy has been transferred to uh to
Christians now uh be begins to be slowly
translated into legal framework as well
so here what we saw just before is that
a theological concept of
superism where uh Christianity replaces
uh Judaism and Israelites and Jews uh in
from as chosen people of God and then
here we begin to have the rise of
Christian Supremacy in the book I'm very
specific that I use the word Supremacy
in a formal legal way as um meaning
power and authority and and that's what
I see transforming theology into
Christian Supremacy into political power
uh when Roman Empire becomes Christian
and begins to implement certain ideas
and to law so here I'll give you one
example but there are others um of how
the um uh the social hierarchy is now
embedded in law and Jer as far as I know
um the the only group that is singled
out for its ethnicity or
specificity uh in law to prohibit
certain things and here is a law that
prohibits Jews uh owning a Christian
slave um and to convert uh uh from a
Christian to a Jew this is ostensibly
about about uh conversion uh but there
is no prohibition of um Jews owning any
slaves or Christians owning Christian
slaves so that's that's the first
significance and differentiation and
later on um it will be uh transformed
into also discourse of uh of power there
are other uh laws that are gradually in
the L Roman Christian Empire introduced
Jews not being able to uh hold public
office uh uh restrictions on Jews as
Witnesses and so on and so forth um the
this language then again I I do a little
bit more detail in in the book but this
language then gets transformed and
introduced and included in Canon long um
in the 13th century um and uh and it is
much more couched in a in a theological
explanation returning to the question of
crucifixion um and that is that Jews are
uh pun punished uh and are by for their
role in the crucifixion and the
punishment is the the Perpetual
servitude uh and therefore and this is
the language of
of arrogance and insolence that emerges
Jews ought not to be ungrateful to us
Christians not requite Christian favores
uh with contumely and intimacy with
contempt and uh and then the the Pope uh
asks the French rulers to restrain the
excesses of Jews that they shall not
dare raise the their neck bowed under
the Yoke of Perpetual servitude against
the reverence of Christian faith lest
the children of a free woman should be
slaves to the children of a slave but
rather as slaves rejected by God
recognize themselves as the slaves of
Those whom Christ's death set set free
at the same time as it enslaved them
henceforth the perfidious Jews should
not in any other way there grow insolent
and in Canan law and church it keeps
coming back that Jews uh are guilty and
consigned to Perpetual servitude they
exchange servitude they owe that they
attempt to exchange the servitude they
owe to Christians for dominion over
there you begin to to not begin but you
see the language of power here in Ence
and then a repetition that as as long as
they persist in their errors they should
recognize through experience that they
have been made slaves while Christians
have been made free through Jesus Christ
God our Lord and that it is iniquitous
that the children of the free woman
should serve the children of a maid
servant in secular law it is translated
into prohibition of Jews having
Christian servants again restrictions on
how many
Jews could be Witnesses against
Christians and um also um the uh
restrictions on public office and and so
on so
forth um let you think this is an
premodern idea but you here you can you
can hear the Echoes of that language
from
1945 in in Poland just after the war a
bishop of Kel me in at the meeting with
Jewish um Community leader says you know
that Jews are talented Merchants doctors
and lawyers and Poland is destroyed and
needs its strikes why don't Jews do what
they are capable of why do they engage
in politics can you imagine what it
looks like when a priest comes to a
Ministry and a Jewish woman is sitting
there God knows from where and treats
our clergy with superiority and
insolence so here you also have a
gendered aspect but it shows you here
that language of hierarchy and the and
Jews in a position of power um uh giving
a sense of of sense of superiority
unearned superiority and insolence as as
the the bishop here um here shows um so
what we what we have is we have the uh
the essentially theology turning into
Supremacy in in the legal format uh and
those the law Ries the idea of Christian
superiority and the social position of
Jews in in legal terms that they cannot
do certain things there are laws against
them and that affirms a sense of um of
Christian domination uh both in itself
for themselves but also against Jews and
the the you know questions of contempt
and uh and unease with Jews in any kind
of positions that do not conform to that
position of
servitude um so that's when we have this
um rise of the Trope of Jewish power
this discomfort with Jews in any other
position than the position of servitude
um and seen as unar and undeserved uh
social uh position this is translated
into visual language ubiquitous medieval
um imagery of the eesan synagoga EES are
representing Christianity as this uh
dominant Queen and synagoga as this
humiliated
blindfolded Maiden uh sometimes there
are a couple of images where she's not
blindfolded but she's still uh seen as a
as a main against the queen queen uh
Christian Queen elesia um and again that
iconography continues in even into the
um 18th century although it does become
less you is from the 16th century on so
what about racism how does it play a
role this this whole thing plays a role
in racism and that comes in at the
moment when Europe begins to expand
across the uh Atlantic and begins to
engage in the um in the transatlantic
slave trade and we begin to see a shift
in I iconography and I'll show you that
in a moment but what we see is um uh a
in application of these concepts of
powers of the idiom of power uh for Jews
uh obviously we see it in as an idiom um
and although in a servitude and
enslavement but it it translates into
affirming of the lower status of
Christians as inferior uh of Jews uh in
Christianity as inferior to Christians
and again habits of thinking of Jews as
inferior in the case of black people
there's actual
enslavement um so it's not the language
and the idea that comes first but it's
the enslavement uh that is come comes
first um the subjections to enslavers
the P the question of power to
dehumanize there's a a phrase in uh one
of the slave narratives um the power to
the human is I can put you in my pocket
by selling you um and the black people
who were enslaved had no legal power
there was uh violence and exploitation
again there is violence and exploitation
in different ways um against Jews in
their inferior position in Christian
Europe uh but here there is this direct
uh slave slave uh enslaver and enslaved
person P violence and exploitation but
again it contributes also to this um to
thinking about black black people as per
perpetually inferior and in fact
inflects our language the word which is
so ubiquitously used now and I urge
people not to use it to
denigrate uh the nigr in in Latin gains
in the early modern period the meaning
that we use it now as as demeaning as
degrading to denigrate to the de mean
and to degrade but it's essentially
means to make someone black so it's to
mean to degrade someone to a black
person status and that's why I think we
should we should stop using this word
but iconography this iconographically it
also transforms the Ecclesia now is
transformed into Queen Europa Europa
Regina um where she is still a Christian
Queen uh and is has very similar posture
shown as very similar posture as the um
as the Ecclesia from the medieval period
but now she does not rule over the
synagoga but she rules over and
dominates over the other continents and
again that iconography becomes
ubiquitous um in this early modern work
by chesar aripa uh which describes how
painters should paint these different
different figures but including the
continents uh Europa is described as
this queen um uh with abundance of food
knowledge and power and the other uh
continents are in various state of
undress and uh and civilization but
until the 18th century Africa is still
um not racialized as black it was only
um by the late 16th and uh early 18 I
mean the by the late 17th and early 18th
century that we begin to see Africa as
racialized as um as black black and that
is certainly influenced by the various
books that uh that uh focus on the
religions and of the Buddha of the
peoples of outside of Europe uh that
begin to emerge in the late 17th century
on
this is again translate the idea here we
see it in law and we see it
in law that is very similar to the laws
of the Roman Empire of uh regulating who
can own other other people uh other
human beings as as slaves and in the um
uh act concerning servants and slaves in
Virginia we see a hierarchy of both race
and religion um so um no negro mulat or
Indian so these are racial groups all
although Christian right so they may be
Christian or Jews mes and mamans that is
non-christians and or other infidels
should P purchase a Christian SL servant
nor any other except of their own
complexion but if any negro mulat Indian
Jew more Maman or other Infidel uh
should uh should per purchase any
Christian white servant the said servant
shall ipof Factor become free so here we
have Christianity and whiteness
associated with freedom but religion and
and rays are in that in that area of uh
a lower area inferior area subject to um
to enslavement um and liberte is um
displayed as this white woman and again
in a very similar iconographic language
as the Ecclesia earlier and then Europa
later
and uh America uh interestingly changes
race once the United States um emerges
as a as an independent power and America
is now represented as col Colombia uh as
a white woman compared to that America
shown in the early modern period and
again that Colombia is explicit the a
white woman displayed in the 19th
century and on
um so what we have we have here a
somewhat replaced um in inverted order
first comes enslavement then the
development of the idea of race to
justify the the Europeans were really
struggling especially in the
enlightenment period with justifying the
enslavement of other human beings and
had to find justification so raise
became and difference became an
explanation and therefore and from that
um emerged the ideology of racism and
the ideology of white supremacy again we
have white supremacy in law earlier but
the
ideology um so and that again is
contrasted that U that order is
contrasted with what we've seen earlier
where the idea of of superiority comes
before the actual law and actual
domination but none the nonetheless the
two converge in uh White Christian
Supremacy and for me that was very
important because when when we've seen
uh especially in the aftermath of George
Floyd's death um all the that it's it's
white supremacy white supremacy uh
people often forgot that it's actually
white Christian Supremacy because the uh
the the both the law the history but
also the people who espoused it it
really do not see Jews as part of that
order and we've seen it certainly in
2017 in Charlottesville uh where the
white supremacists were chanting Jew
shall will not replace us um again
echoing the replacement Theory from a
different perspective and a um and
expressing white Christian
Supremacy in the modern period the
premodern the premodern set these
hierarchies and habits of thinking about
Jews and black people as a
inferior um and uh and but but these
ideas then clashed with the modern ideas
of equality and citizenship how do those
uh social hierarchies then phase up to
the ideas of equality and citizenship
and as the modern Nations at the end of
the 18th century were inventing the new
idea of we um uh we the people um and
seeking what the this meant the question
was whether Jews and black people belong
in the new wi and in fact during the
French Revolution uh the same people
that were debating the citizenship about
of Jews were also debating the
eligibility of black and free black
people not just enslaved people but free
black people for citizenship um so this
uh this is certainly um certainly an
issue and uh and Jews by that time are
already racialized as Oriental and as
coming from Asia and the question
becomes whether they can not just as not
just on the religious basis also as you
can see in um the Johan Miis uh text uh
the law of Moses does law of Moses uh
make citizenship and full integration of
the Jews impossible I think it does they
will never become fully integrated the
way Catholics lutherans Germans W and
French live together right the religion
uh ostensibly Pro prevents Jews from
this integration uh but there's also
this racial they are they them from Asia
and differ from others um but the issue
was um not human rights and civil rights
at some level of residence but really
political rights the equality of rights
as Citizens and active citizens uh the
same questions were in the Netherlands
do we continue regard Jews as people as
alien residents or regard them at
Dutchman um are they fellow beings um or
or are they equal on equal footing with
Dutchman um and again collectively
speaking Jews cannot share in our Dutch
social rights as Citizens as long as
they are Jews right there this religion
Jewish is and religion preventing them
um and one of the members of the debate
said well that we need to decide whether
we in the Netherlands honor the rights
of men or only Christian men the rights
of citizens are only of Rights of
Christian citizens so again this is
around religion uh protecting the
Christian Supremacy in Europe but there
is this element of racialization already
then and uh and it will um it will
become more apparent in the 19th century
but again these debates over Jews and
people who are debating it keep um the
question of people of color black people
as well in their minds and here is from
the same debate of a Jew Jewish
citizenship in the Netherlands um a
reference to uh the slaves of San
Domingo uh that it was it was too fast
right Jews shouldn't be given the
citizenship rights too fast they should
be um the the the pace should be slower
because look at what happened in San
Domingo um the
untimely equality granted to the slaves
of San Domingo served to the destruction
of that French
population um and again it continues
that is it Jew Christian rights for whom
were these rights developed uh Bruno
Bower uh who sees ju as a problem um
says that this would all that debate was
really only for the Christian world uh
not for for Jews uh bhel marah um the
person behind the anti-semitic league
and therefore the new term the neologism
anti-Semitism again affirms that Jews
are Semitic race completely different
with Homeland and Palestine and then
turns into the question of um of uh
political power and in fact he affirms
that when it comes to religious
persecutions he
I even take the Jews under my
unconditional protection but it was
about sharing the political power that
but that political equality um that in
his mind led to alien alien Jewish
domination and uh he turns into voting
an electoral power electing the alien he
calls Masters and making them
legislators and judges right Jew Jews in
power H similarly a German um German uh
historian um Henry Fant trka uh refers
to emancipation or the granting of
citizenship to uh to Jews and his
discomfort with the literal uh parity
right he they demanded the literal P
parity but we Germans are after all a
Christian Nation and Jews are only a
minority um so that habit of thinking of
Jews is inferior to Christians that
we've seen developing over centuries is
uh playing itself out in a new political
situation of Jews as Citizens and um
again uh font also racializes Jews as
orientals and that racialization goes
back actually to these religious debates
uh of the uh 17th early modern period uh
where Jews are Judaism is typically
discussed in the context of biblical
observances of Jews and therefore they
are placed um in uh in in in Palestine
right in in the Holy Land not in Europe
and the these books tend to be kind of
uh Proto evolutionary they show the
evolution of of um different uh Western
different um religions and Judaism is
always the sort of protto religion from
from which emerg Christianity in
different denominations of Christianity
and then there are all these other um
non-western uh groups which also have uh
animal sacrifices and do different
things in fact one book in
1705 uh Jax depos the customs of East
Indians so in in India in Asia uh with
those of Jews and Jews of antiquity and
here is a page showing um the uh the
Charming of the serpents um is
supposedly happening in India um and
comparing it to uh Moses and his staff
and this and the serpent in um in the in
the Bible and that of course leads to
exclusion Jews to Palestina uh Jews to
Palestine you can see again that uh that
racialization and the caricature of Jews
as these ugly uh people were
not the Jew the caricature Jew that get
me thinking after after Baldwin's quote
H so again that kind of process of De
europeanization of Jews of seeing them
as alien as not being part of Europe uh
leads to uh that social exclusion and ex
and political exclusion uh as well and
if the debate was framed around religion
or racialized religion in Europe um in
the United States that debate is create
is a racial lines and here we have uh
the first kind of genuine debate about
what what citizenship meant in the
United States the word exists but it's
not defined in the Missouri debate and
one of the representatives from Virginia
uh spoke in the language this is what
when I read it sounded like we the white
people we the Christian people how it is
very similar to the echo to Indian free
Negroes mad slaves tell me not that the
constitution when it speaks of We the
People means these the argument in favor
including the class of of citizens free
uh uh people of color goes too far they
of course meant we the white people
right they were European descendants so
that could not have been and again Canan
Nigro whose ancestors were important
important to this country and so that
slaves become a member of a political
Community think about can the Jews and
their law can become part of the
citizens and equal rights and be une
equal parts as us be can they be
entitled become entitled to all the
rights of privileges immunities
guaranteed that uh by that instrument of
the citizen um so what we see is that as
we' see in the modern idea of equality
ideal of equality clashes with the
established social
hierarchies and FN essentially they come
to the conclusion that no Jews and black
people do not belong to the Wii and
again uh and when they do attain legal
equality forced in America through Civil
War and in the unit in in Europe
reluctantly granted through the legal
transformations of uh European States um
that equality is seen as unearned
usurped and uh and out of place and we
see this today I'm uh in contemporary
echo of that exclusion uh inferiority
and power um this is a a shot from a a
ad you can find on YouTube from
2018 um about highlighting The
Connoisseur of chaos George Source
funding the left and causing all the
sort of racial unrest that draws on an
earlier Trope of Jews causing racial
unrest and the Civil Rights era um uh
race mixing finance and led by Jews
again very similar idea behind it and
more recently we've seen it um in the
case of um of Al district attorney Alvin
BR who is black
the man on Manhattan when he charged um
Donald Trump uh with uh with crimes um
that's one of those demonstrated George
sorus pounds at D Abra Google it um so I
thought I I wanted to share a few
concluding thoughts on how um thinking
and expanding and moving out and
engaging with other fields is really
help helpful for one's own field it's
very difficult and it's very uh feels
one feels very
vulnerable uh exploring an a a field in
which one is not thin you sort of
realize how many things we observe over
Decades of work and how you you can
navigate your own field but when you
engage with a new field um you learn uh
you have to learn not just you know
facts but also historiographic debate
and so on so forth but but what I think
thinking black studies really helped me
rethink anti-Semitism two ways a um
moving beyond the emotional history of
emotion of um history of hat you know
the longest hatred in that way but
thinking along the structures and laws
and uh and oppression and
power but also and that became really
clear after uh October 7 seven is that
um black studies um and highlight the
experience of black people under
influenc and impacted by uh by racism
the the the scholars focus on what
racism does
to people how it oppress how that
oppression functions and how it impacts
those uh whom it targets the field of
anti-Semitism for focuses on on
anti-semites um analyzes how
anti-semites think and repeats and and
traces the anti-semitic idea uh we do
not we have not paid attention to the
structures of Law and power and we have
not as Scholars paid attention to what
anti-Semitism or anti-jewish animals
more broadly beyond the modern period
does to um to Jews and to their uh to
their EXP experience to their bodily
experience we studied the the Jew and
how the Jew the image of the Jew the
caricature emerges so I'm going to stop
here so there is a little time for
discussion um and I look forward to
hearing what you have to
say uh thank you Professor tedo that was
really really fantastic um and
thought-provoking and there's several uh
great questions already in the queue so
for those of you who have never come to
yit online before please put your
questions in the Q&A chat feature um I
forgot to say this in my introduction
you could have been doing this some of
you were doing it all throughout the
talk um and uh we have about 10 to 15
minutes so we'll just dive in uh the
first question uh thank you for this
discussion can you please shed light on
how Jews of color especially black Jews
factor into your comparative analysis
while being at the intersection of both
marginalized identities this is a great
question um because I think the and this
is especially uh true for the
later um more recent um you know now now
a few decades but relatively recent in
uh American Jewish uh
historiography um the question of sort
of Jewish whiteness and and you know how
the Jews become white the price of
whiteness and all that um and uh and I
do talk about it from a legal
perspective um I use uh um Ian Haney's
Lopez's phrase white by law that is that
in in the United States because Jews
could immigrate and be naturalized they
were white by law they were considered
light white by law there were other um
obviously uh forms of discrimination
against Jews in Maryland and some other
places there may have been even
restrictions on on voting and other
places but from a national perspective
Ive um Jews um were could immigrate and
were considered white by law that's and
and Laura liman Arnold liman has shown a
very interesting tale of of some Jews
from the colonies going to England sort
of becoming certified and and as as
white or european at least and coming
into um into uh the United States and
being naturalized uh but in
the point that I wanted to make is that
um that uh that discourse of Jewish
whiteness uh which I think is very
problematic um is also erasing the
experience of Jews of color um who as as
the the questioner mentioned are sort of
bridging it and and that experience
again I'm not an expert and I there are
Scholars who have written uh about about
it uh but they Jews of color especially
black um Jews are are caught in that
especially in American again in in that
it's very different in Israel there's a
very different um social hierarchy there
um but uh but in America um they were
not quite see seen as Jewish by by
European Jews and they they were not
quite SE seen as um as having the
experience of black Americans and and so
there is this this sort of in in in
betweenness uh
here yeah that there are two additional
questions um that are sort of along the
same theme Al we might have already
addressed the the thrust of it um one on
how uh black and Jewish communities can
build solidarity amongst each other um
and another on this the consequences of
this shift uh in the uh Jewish whiteness
question and the specific phrasing is in
the eyes of many black citizens and
theorist Jews are white when did this
occur and and its consequences yeah
and and certainly
um I mean James Baldwin has this famous
essay um and I don't remember the exact
title but um blacks hate Jews not
because they are blacks are anti-semitic
because they hate Jews because they're
white or
yeah something like that from the
1960s and one and and you know he is
essentially questioning the position of
American Jews and immigrants H in the
United States as white and what it does
in in that and there is this breakdown
right even the 1930s and
1940s uh these intellectuals are
engaging with each other by 1960s we
have a breakdown of that and um one of
the question that I pose is um this is
this is certainly the case but why is
James Baldwin singling out
Jews right he's obviously uh writes in
many places about whiteness
um but I'm not I'm I I know he mentioned
Irish here and there and he mentioned
Italian that you know they arrive and
they become white in the United States
and all of us actually become white when
we when we are feeling all of us all of
us of this complexion that I have become
white when we feel out censuses and
other thing the United States law
functions along the sort of um even if
we don't identify in racial terms right
so yes everybody becomes white uh yet he
he focuses on Jews and to
me that also signals a a kind of
discomfort with Jew is whiteness and
perhaps an
unacknowledged and I'm not just talking
here about Baldwin but
unacknowledged
um objection to Jews exercising the
rights of citizens and yes citizenship
in America
was framed along racial lines and
whiteness but when we reframe the
question that
are coming as all immigrants are coming
and trying to exercise their rights as
citizen rather than achieve whiteness
that might change the discourse but then
that may also um change the the
perception or or it may highlight the
discomfort with Jewish equality as well
that I I think there's is at play a
little bit in that in there that it's um
that the fact that Jews are singled out
out in that discourse of whiteness um
over other groups that are also you know
coming and are white um signals to me
there is something going on in that way
and of course there is this expectation
that an oppressed would have a
solidarity with the with other oppress
and so on so forth that plays um that
plays uh plays a role and um and there
is a breakdown there are all kinds of
complexity issues after especially after
the Civil Rights er um sometimes it's
it's you know talking past each other's
um historical
experiences um the objections to
affirmative actions that some Jewish
groups had um had a very different
historical meaning for Jews especially
many of whom were immigrants from Europe
for whom who saw it as quotas and and a
potential problem for black Americans
obviously affirmative action was
entirely different so that when when
Jews are siding against it that feels
like a betrayal so this this complex um
uh you know cultural relations but also
the you know the relations of um of
habits of thinking and yes racial
thinking as
well yeah so to follow up I'm going to
use moderator's prerogative because this
is also been thinking about these issues
myself um to follow up on that question
about how uh uh solidarity could be
built between black and Jewish
communities in the 21st century one of
the things that strikes me I mean I i'
I've read de Bo's essay on the Warsaw
Ghetto uh many times um and several
friend several friends of mine are
working on you know interracial and um
Interfaith anti-fascist organizing in
the 30s and 40s um and so it does seem
like there is this and and maybe this
helps to explain why Baldwin singled out
Jewish people in as as as the question
of whiteness there is this sense that
there was this housian day of you know
genuine uh uh anti-racist and anti-
anti-semitic organizing and
solidarity uh in the 30s and 40s um was
that just a ephemeral moment is it
possible to build that kind of politics
again too much happened since then um um
well a couple of things so I think the
um so first I realized I didn't answer
the first question about how to build a
solidarity but I think this this your
question as well ties to it I think that
um that uh we need to um we need to
understand sort of where the enemies are
right in that way and I and I think
understanding the sort of common
roots of that that it's it's about power
and domination how it builds and how I
mean in in the in the story I tell these
stories don't necessar
intersect at a certain point but they
run on kind of parallel tracks um
because the Dynamics of power and
dominations are similar it's just that
they are along religious lines and
racialized religious lines on one side
of the Atlantic and then along racial
lines on the other side of the Atlantic
and
um um when Jews obviously arrive in the
United States in the 19th century or
even earlier in the 18th century lateer
18th century After the Revolution or or
um uh the 19 Early Republic they
[Music]
are they they love the idea that they
are seen as as equal because religion is
part of the protected clause in the
Constitution right whereas whereas the
system of law is very racial in in in
the United States set along racial lines
and I think that one of the things that
um that
um might help people sort of understand
that a the Dynamics of power and
oppression are are built out of the same
vocabulary and the same Concepts but two
when um when we have that the discourse
of Jes white is flattening some of that
complexity and at the same time the
denial oh no no Jews are not white this
kind of reflexive denial um also
flattens some of the and and and some of
that complexity because there is this
legal aspect of H of a again becoming
citizens and therefore having political
rights um being able to vote
um and and and with that comes a lot
of there is a there's there's meaning to
the word political
Capital um and when when a whole
population like black Americans were um
targeted at this franchisement and we
see it today as well with the various
ger mandering uh to exclude black
populations from voting or limit the
power of their vote um
that political capital is smaller and I
in the book I talk about the sort of the
reaction and what happened to the
exclusion of Jews of of um uh of
um one one Jewish um individual from
hotel and in both um in Saro Springs and
then later on the Lake Plaza incident
with uh Melville Dewey of the dwey
decimal system um there is this
political Capital that Jewish citizens
can use and organize and push uh for
change that black individuals didn't
have because they didn't they were their
their voting and their political Powers
restricted so I
think opening up and having these
conversations is important on on uh on
laying this out and showing some of the
the habits of thinking about both groups
that those dominant groups that that uh
both were in in which both both groups
were were oppressed in some ways is also
important to
understand um well we are the the hon of
the of the 1940s whether that was a
moment yes so one of the thing is that
again this this comes in because the
Nazis used
um American racial laws as a model for
the nurenberg laws against Jews and this
is in the 1930s when we have when when
Nazis are Den naturalizing Jews when
they're limiting the
um rights of citizenship when they're
introducing misation laws and so on so
forth where um black Americans are
seizing the moment and seeing
look this is what we've been going here
right it's the moment of of of common
cause and and and and moment that that
helps highlight the plight of of black
Americans in in the moment and certainly
Jewish
intellectuals um are are part of that
and they are seeing this uh and then um
you know just as there is this this
discomfort with Jewish power for a
different
reason there was this discomfort with
black power one on the one black power
emerged and we see these sort of
fissures and and and
breakdown and again um and and some
again not all Jews were on on you know
on board with civil rights and all that
some Jews were and some then left the
bandwagon some stayed um and I think
thinking along the um the lines of both
the different views and not seeing Jews
as a as a one group whether white or
always you know on the side of uh one
struggle or the other um and the the
other thing oh I had another thoughts
that wanted to say but it escaped me I
might come back well I mean we are
actually at time okay so it won't come
back no but but you know on
a I'll offer one concluding thought of
my own that um one of the great lessons
of of Christian Supremacy
which again is a fantastic book I highly
recommend everybody in the audience go
and buy a copy um is that politics
especially group politics are complex um
but they are sort of structured and
mediated by oh no did
this did you no no no finish your
thought oh no but they're structured
mediated by received law received
ideology we sort of received um
structures did you did you remember yes
my my last thought was that uh you know
in terms of common moment and and again
how our language might might might be
careful is this question you know
sometimes black anti-Semitism or Jewish
racism and I think we have to um kind of
move away from that and and ask
ourselves whether there is anything
particular about anti-jewish sentiments
within the black community that we could
call it black anti-Semitism or whether
it is just anti-semitism
that or anti-jewish animist that exists
within a some some group some members of
the of the community and similarly
Jewish racism is that such a thing as
Jewish racism or is it C some
individuals who may Express racism or
believe racist ideas and are racism
racism is a Jewish or is it just racism
uh so I think one of the ways to to
maybe bridge is to give up these labels
of p
pathologizing uh Prejudice by adding the
the um adjectives before them and
actually analyze and unpack them whether
it is just simply um simply a form of
prejudice bigotry on one group of the
other and not pathologize it as as if it
was a single singular of the other well
I think that's a fantastic note to end
on I want to thank you again Professor
tedar for the talk I want to thank
everybody in the audience for coming out
this afternoon I especially want to
thank because I've been looking over the
guest list um all of my students who
have logged on today I I I said this
morning in class you should come to this
talk and I'm glad at least some of you
did um and so thank you all so so much
um and we will see everyone hopefully
sometime soon at the at the next event
thank you so much for having me thank
you the students and everybody for
coming thank you bye